on the surface the dap does look like
any everyday handshake but the dap is a
gesture of solidarity it's not just a
handshake
[Music]
under my Hamilton I'm an
interdisciplinary artist I've been
looking at Dan shake the DAP from a very
specific and unique african-american
experience so acronym for dignity and
pride and it was coined by black
soldiers there to be a known war you
have the sixties and all these political
movements and there's a racial
consciousness that was hiding now this
war is happening in there moved into
this whole nother world you take these
young men and you put them in this space
away from home they're gonna make a home
with each other and solidary became
really important so that's what adapt
was born out of it was a communication
that I'm not above you you know about me
was side-by-side together and that's the
original dad as black soldiers were
coming home they were introducing this
thing that they didn't um to their
friends and they never was on and on and
on and it is where it is today five on a
black hand side is the photographic
series in which I've been looking at the
DAP photographed for about 120
handshakes the historical narratives are
very important to me but that kind of
new imagining new vantage point is what
I'm interested in but I wanted to get at
something deeper than what the
photographs alone were doing step line
is a performance piece we're really
trying to bring out that narrative of
black soldiers going to Vietnam War I
was always interested in these really
genuine but also complex expressions
within black culture dabbe line became a
visible reflection of very quiet moments
between a black minute the goal of what
I'm doing with the whole project is to
bring it back to that very specific
origin and give very specific a real
credit to this particular radical
gesture that has all this thing inside
of it we have to recognize the black
experience as a truly American
experience and then what can I do to
move this narrative Ford
[Music]